with what did you not love that that
rally in Grand Rapids unbelievable we
got all the highlights if you missed it
welcome to Hannity and a busy news night
rush limbaugh will be joining us tonight
Don junior also joining us moments away
but first President Trump he just
wrapped up a massive rally in Western
Michigan where by the way 140,000 people
wanted to go to a you know 15 thousand
seat arena and he was touting his
impressive record of accomplishments you
know the ones the media never talked
about and despite facing a political
witch hunt for over two years the
president has guided this country on the
right path with regulations and tax cuts
and energy independence for the first
time in 70 years
a booming economy record low
unemployment for African Americans
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans women
in the workplace and youth unemployment
the u.s. is now again the leader and the
envy of the world why do you think so
many people want to come here now the
haters were wrong the media lied for two
consecutive plus years the deep state
thankfully has now been exposed and
those responsible will be held
accountable for the president who
promised to make America great again you
know when people wear that hat it's a
trigger for the left promises made
promises kept take a look this has been
an incredible couple of weeks for
America
the economy is roaring the Isis
Caliphate is defeated 100%
and after three years of lies and smears
and slander the Russia hoax is finally
dead the president the crowd on fire
tonight
oh I forgot to tell you we have a huge
announcement big at the end of the show
all right so while we have been busy
reporting the truth what's happened in
the rest of the media that they have
been waging through a psychotic rage a
political war against the President and
also We the People the smelly Walmart
people the irredeemable deplorable z'
and while we have been driven by facts
and why we don't rush the judgment we
believe in due process they have been
blinded by hatred and rage that's why we
make sure we get it right on this
program clearly almost there very big
story they get it wrong that's why poor
Rachel Maddow with our tin foil hat
conspiracy hat you know has lost all
credibility why CNN and NBC are now
experiencing dramatic ratings decline so
precipitously it's unreal and deserved
and that's why the tinfoil hat
conspiracy theorist Adam shift the only
one left standing facing urging calls
rightly so to resign from his position
atop the house Intel committee take a
look your willingness to continue to
promote a demonstrable false narrative
is alarming the findings of the special
counsel conclusively refute your past
and present assertions and have exposed
you as having abused your position to
knowingly promote false information as
such we have no faith in your ability to
discharge your duties and a commander
consistent with your constitutional
responsibilities and urge your immediate
resignation as chairman of the committee
I think it's immoral
I think it's unethical I think it's
unpatriotic and yes I think it's corrupt
and evidence of collusion I don't think
it's okay that his attorney lie to our
committee there's a different word for
that than collusion and it's called
compromise I will not yield mr. master
you because you must make all of us that
I know she got sponsor
we now remember it was known leaker and
liar Adam Schiff we call him the
Cowardly Schiff on this program who
claimed to have clear evidence with
Trump Russia collusion is promising that
now that of course Robert Muller is
all-powerful twenty-two months twenty
five million dollar probe as did the
nine-month investigation of the FBI and
the House Intel Senate Intel committees
he is in Congress still claiming to have
the smoking gun evidence that those four
investigations did not find President
Trump
well he's calling out the cowardly chef
take a look little pencil-neck Adam
Schiff
it's got the smallest thinnest snake
I've ever seen
he is not a long-ball hitter but i saw
him today well we don't really know
there could still have been some russia
colors
sick sick these are sick people and
there has to be accountability because
it's all lies and they know it's life
there has to be accountability
president's right he's on fire tonight
now we have invited many times the
Cowardly shift on this program present
his damning evidence the one that the
FBI the house Intel the Senate committee
and robert muller didn't find about
russia collusion come make your case
he's always decline coming on this
program and i offered three hours of
radio that's because he's been lying to
you the american people for political
gain but guess what we're announcing
tonight on this program that I have my
own dossier on the Cowardly ship
basically him in his own words 402 plus
years will play him in his own words
I remember whether he actually was
caught on tape colluding with people
that he actually believed were Russian
sources trying to get compromising
materials on Trump to impact our
electoral system
oh he's caught on tape colluding you
cannot make this up this is how dumb
this man is take a look and she met with
Trump and she brought him one our
Russian girl celebrity all guseva who
also known as a person with a strange
reputation Oh her name all get boobs
ever the nature of the comfort month
well there were a pictures of naked
Trump and so Putin was made aware of the
availability of the compromising
material yes of course thank you very
much we will be back in touch with you
through our staff to make arrangements
to obtain these materials for our
committee and and for the FBI and and I
appreciate your reaching out to us it's
like the greatest tape we ever play he's
caught on tape colluding with Russians
unbelievable now California's 28
district well you obviously could do
better shift should resign as a disgrace
but chip is not the only bad actor who
has been utterly humiliated by this
probe also disgraced CIA director turn
BC MSNBC tinfoil hat conspiracy theory
network hack John Brennan he's called
the President on multiple occasions a
traitor pushing collusion conspiracies
as utter fact almost every day and it
turns out yeah he was lying on an
extreme level and tonight we're learning
something very damning about John
Brennan and we will follow this story
Rand Paul earlier today tweeting out a
high-level source telling him that it
was Brennan who insisted that the
unverified fake Clinton bought and paid
for Steele dossier with Russian lies
included in the intelligence report that
Brennan should be asked to now testify
under oath in Congress as soon as
possible in other words Brennan used his
official position as CIA director to
validate the phony Russian Clinton
bought and paid for dossier in other
words was he involved in this hoax was
he trying to set Donald Trump up from
the get-go now that would be a blatant
abuse of power so how is this corrupt is
credited con man how does he have a job
at NBC and elac phone I want to talk to
him now it's our promise to you and we
take this seriously every single night
every single person every member of the
deep State not rank-and-file FBI they're
awesome the greatest law enforcement
agency on the planet but the others the
few we will hold accountable and with
the help of key lawmakers dedicated
investigators equal justice under our
law equal application of our laws will
happen our constitutional rights will be
upheld now take for example ranking
intel member Doug Collins today he
followed up again releasing even more
transcripts from his committees
closed-door Hearings things we'd never
heard before
now this patch included testimony from
Nelly or member Nelly or kandan Han with
Christopher Steele of fusion GPS and he
just happened to be married to the wife
of disgraced DOJ official Bruce [ __ ] he
was once the fourth highest ranking
member at the DOJ now thanks to a
release testimony this is what we
learned today
Nelly or admitted to meeting with
Christopher Steele one day before the
eff
launched its counterintelligence probe
into Trump and Russia in 2016 one day
before
surprise surprise and her DOJ husband
Bruce or was at the meeting and
according to her words and transcript we
learned tonight that Nellie or was
instructed to dig up dirt on Paul
Manafort and Michael Flynn and lo and
behold guess what who ended up being
targeted by the special counsel Paul
Manafort and Michael Flynn and it
doesn't stop there she also admits to
targeting Donald Trump jr. and even the
president's wife Melania and don't
forget as reported by the hills John
Solomon Nellie or even gave her husband
a flash drive with her bought and paid
for Russian lies in the hopes that he
would disseminate it throughout the DOJ
and the FBI remember was leaked to the
media before the election why to
influence the election on behalf of
Hillary Clinton that's not all now
thanks to ORS testimony we know that a
key source for fusion GPS is the very
same Ukrainian lawmaker is accused of
timing the release of sensitive
information about Paul Manafort back in
2016 in order to help Hillary Clinton
win the election Ukrainian interference
in our elections with Hillary with real
evidence they have a tape in that case
now get this irony of all ironies a
court in Ukraine ruled back in December
those actions amounted to meddling in
the 2016 American presidential election
so yeah there was collusion in 2016
bought and paid for by the Clinton
campaign the DNC now on the good side
let not your hearts be troubled the deep
states day of reckoning is just around
the corner
next week congressman Devin Nunez will
be issuing criminal referrals many of
them targeting those who have lied to
Congress committed a criminal conspiracy
there are going to be people now
investigated as we have been calling for
for over two years
president Trump is also last night on
this program he has vowed to release all
FISA documents surrounding quarter-page
a trump campaign associate they spied on
him they denied him his constitutional
rights at the height of the election
which gave him a backdoor to spy on the
Trump campaign
a few corrupt deep state bureaucrats
with the help of Hillary Clinton's
bought and paid for
phony lying Russian dossier now earlier
President Trump had this to say about
the biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in American history that the
media is ignored take a watch the Russia
witch-hunt was a plan by those who lost
the election to try and illegally regain
power by framing innocent Americans many
of them they suffered with an elaborate
hoax they wanted to destroy a movement
like our country has never seen before
the Democrats have to now decide whether
they will continue defrauding the public
with ridiculous
partisan investigations away there they
will apologize to the American people
I've long said the President Trump is
the disrupter we need in the Oval Office
he's not the establishment the swamp
Flint needs to be drained and you know
what iconoclastic fighting to keep
promises imagine that from a politician
he has from the get-go challenged all
conventional thinking and in doing so
exposed a dark bureaucratic underbelly
that is within our federal government in
doing so he really is making America
great again
and his statistics while they speak for
themselves according to Obama's former
attorney general though Eric Holder
America country we love the beat back
fascism and Nazism and communism and
Imperial Japan yeah it's not a great
country never was when I hear these
things about let's make America great
again I think to myself exactly when did
you think America was great it certainly
wasn't when people were enslaved it
certainly wasn't when women didn't have
the right to vote it certainly wasn't
when the LGBT community was denied the
rights to which it was entitled it takes
us back to I think an American past that
never in fact really existed no never a
perfect country but we have paid the
price for freedom for more people on the
face of this earth there's never been a
country that has accumulated more power
abused at less and used it for the
Advancement of the human condition war
than the United States of America I'm
pretty sure Holder won't be the last
successful wealthy figure in the
Democratic Party really want to run on
trashing the greatness of America but
tonight the good people of Michigan they
have a very different take come 2020
America's greatness will prevail let's
watch each of us here tonight is united
by the same timeless values we believe
in the American Constitution and the
American rule
of law we believe in the dignity of work
and the sanctity of life we believe that
faith and family not government and
bureaucracy are the true American Way we
believe in religious liberty the right
to free speech and the right to keep and
bear arms
[Applause]